you wanna know what i think is gonna
happen next oh tell me i think uh
democrats are gonna win in georgia
and then joe biden's gonna come gonna
become president and then they're gonna
pack the supreme court maybe maybe
because you might get
you might get like a mansion democrat
who's like i refuse to allow this
yeah but uh the reason why i think
they're gonna win in georgia is because
what i've often said is trump's not on
the ballot and people don't like the
republican party
they like trump and they like the new
wave of trump republicans
this it's a smaller group relative to
political establishment
but the runoff in georgia is on january
5th on january 6th
alex jones many others say they're going
to be in dc with 10 million people
yeah how many people from georgia are
gonna pack their bags on the fifth
to drive perhaps not vote in georgia
exactly i know it's it's concerning for
sure that that can't happen though
tim i mean you're right look look let's
say let's wargame this if the democrats
win in georgia
i think without question they will try
to pack the court
yep don't believe me this isn't what i
think they've said it
they're going to make two more states
would probably be democrat senators
representing those who are going to do a
dc and puerto ric and puerto rico
they're going to probably ditch the
electoral college
again don't believe me they've said it
that would require that
i think that would require two-thirds
ratification so that they can they're
gonna try to do it but
it won't matter i don't i don't think
you know
i think they've already changed the
rules beyond the election yeah i see
what you mean it won't matter yeah
yeah look the fact that they've done
universal mail-in voting
they've obliterated the chain of custody
for our election system they've ripped
security away from it nancy pelosi
wanted to get rid of voter id
they want no security in their elections
while they screamed that we had insecure
elections for four years
and listen every pundit in at least in
the state of pennsylvania
the general sentiment is well democrat
in the white house republicans pick up
seat
in the off year right that's just always
been the historical trend what the party
that holds the white house the opposite
party picks up seats that year
but in the state of pennsylvania i don't
think the people realize the paradigm
shift that happened in 2020 there was
something called with as part of act 77
called the automatic
opt-in so during the highest
presidential voter turnout in our
nation's history
the democrats sent out something like
two plus million mail-in ballots
if you got a ballot application and you
check the automatic opt-in you get a
ballot sent to you
for every election until the day that
you die and if you're a democrat
probably after that as well but my
my point is you did the idea that
all of those people all of those
democrats are going to get ballots in
the off psych
and the off cycle right so they're
feasibly
feasibly they could have a presidential
voter turnout in a mid-cycle in the
state of pennsylvania which is
this democrats only get elected with low
information voters
and i'm not saying that to disparage
your average democrat voter
but the fact that you've had democrats
talking about lowering the voting age to
16
is all the proof i need to say democrats
survive off of low information voters
people who aren't
so listen why do why do they want
universal mail in voting
well the left says to make it easier for
people to vote
should someone who has no idea what
they're voting for or who they're voting
for vote
my personal opinion no that's why i
don't like
we talked about quite a bit getting rid
of the d and
democrat republican getting rid of
parties on ballots imagine you got you
got a
flyer in the mail or i imagine you go to
vote and you see conor lamb sean parnell
no democrat no republican just the names
the only people are gonna get the votes
are the people who are like i like sean
parnell or i like conor lamb
now what happens is you get a bout in
the mail and they go democrat
they don't know what they're voting for
they don't know why they're voting for
it and that's what democrats thrive on
we can't function if people just are
saying i don't know party boop
and they're not really voting for
anything other than team then you end up
with people who
sell you out to say china and that's
what we're headed towards
uh you know what man i think the
democrats this was their
uh their reckless abandon their
desperate attempt to get enough votes to
beat trump by waking as like
waking many people to politics getting
them as active as possible and angry as
possible
and now we're all sitting sitting here
watching this relief bill this
ridiculous omnibus spending bill
everybody basically hates it everybody's
democrats hate it left
the left has said it conservatives say
that trump supporters hate it
they're they're they're throwing it in
our faces and laughing
so at this point i think the
establishment
is rather content mitch mcconnell is
already
telling other senators not to support
trump on january 6.
uh you know don't don't do it he's
already
planning to override trump's veto trump
wants to view the defense spending bill
well the republicans never had his back
they were only forced to have his back
because they knew that trump had the
support of the people well let me tell
you man
i think that's a huge look if if that's
the case if what you say is true
you know it'd be a huge mistake for any
republican in the house or the senate to
to run away or distance themselves from
the president he
is by far the most popular president in
our nation's history period
and and no i don't include joe biden in
that count
because i'm sorry look you could say
what
i i don't want to get you in trouble on
youtube or whatever so i i just
i don't believe that he got 80 million
votes the guy the guy never left his
basement
he doesn't inspire anybody he did not
have a single message he can't string
together a single coherent sentence
there and and this idea of of widespread
voter fraud i disagree with it
i disagree with that i think i think the
fraud was very surgical
and if you look at the the red waves
happened everywhere
except for in areas that dem and
counties the democrats
absolutely had to win it was a zero-sum
game look at john james in michigan
look at derrick van orden navy seal in
wisconsin those two guys
lost me and pa 17 in the areas that
democrats
had to win and counties that they had to
win
to carry key battleground states they
want red wave
everywhere else in allegheny county the
president didn't lose the state of
pennsylvania
in philadelphia right that's not where
he lost he lost the state of
pennsylvania
in allegheny county where joe biden had
the second highest voter turnout
ever to lyndon b johnson in 1964
but in it and by the way by the way joe
biden got a couple thousand fewer votes
than linda b johnson in 1964 but
in 1964 allegheny county was 30 more
populous there
there is a very easy
simple explanation the media had been
screaming orange man bad nonsense
that's correct and then they launched
universal mail in
voting and so what i was saying was in
the month
or two leading up to the election you're
going to have this is really funny i
don't know if i don't know who said this
to me i said you're gonna have a parent
the mail in ballots are gonna come into
the house and they're gonna go to their
kids who are like you know 18
20 and they're going to be like did you
vote yet you got to vote you got to vote
for the democrat the kids were booked i
don't care mom
and then i think it was maybe michael
malus who said no it's gonna be the way
around the college kids come home
and go to their parents and go we got
our belts you gotta vote and you gotta
vote for the democrats and the parents
go sure fine whatever
i think one of the reasons why we see
many of these votes were justified to
nobody else was because these people
don't vote they were like orange man bad
have a nice day
well look a coup a couple things like
let's just let's see let's just even say
there was
let's just see there was no fraud right
none whatsoever i still
bill barr said there was well of course
there was fraud right there was but bill
barr said not enough to affect the
outcome
this was a new statement too look yeah
look my point is
let's just pretend that there was none
this is still
not a free and fair election you had the
media parroting
non-stop lies about the president every
single day the mainstream media most in
the media and then you had big tech
censoring stories that would have
probably made people
switch their vote from joe biden to
donald trump the hunter biden story is a
prime example of that yeah the oldest
newspaper in the country right the new
york post
come out with a story that was perfectly
vetted fact-checked perfectly you had
tony babaliski come out
the media ignored it 100 like something
like 10
of the people who learned about this
after the fact said hey if they knew
about this hunter biden story going into
november 3rd they probably would not
have voted for for joe biden
and that right there in and of itself is
enough to switch
the outcome of the election so the
democrats control the cultural
institutions
and yeah and so yeah it's it's a it's a
problem and now
now now with with act 77 in in the
mail-in ballots specifically in
pennsylvania they control the ballot box
too
dude you have secret ballot counting
days after the election was done oh
november 5th and 6th they're still
counting
on this foreign proprietary voter
machine canadian
well canadian corporation built this i
don't know
proprietary voting machine that counts
and see i don't know anything about days
after they need to know how many they
need
no no it's insane the voting machine pro
the problem with the the voting machines
is not that they're counting in secret
there's proper tabulation on these
things the problem is that
when trump campaign and others sued they
were they were
the lawsuits were thrown out on
procedural grounds the problem is
that there were proper impropers that we
don't know in errors well we don't know
anything
no there's no transparency well that's
that's
a lack of transparency i should say that
is arizona when they filed subpoenas
for the voting machines to actually get
the forensic analysis you can see the
vote counts
you can see the signatures they're not
doing it oh they gave us one that's like
one of those
no they clocked it and they said we're
going to court and we're not going to
follow the subpoenas they got subpoenaed
and said f you we won't listen
and in georgia when trump said we want a
hard signature audit they said
no and they did like these sam sample
audits
so every single time there's been
someone saying can we look at these
machines it's been a
no and the one time we did in antrim
county
the report came out saying widespread
that the mission
they claimed in this report there were
intentional errors in like 68 percent
to force adjudication so an election
official could choose where the vote
goes that's the problem
so yeah transparency i i would tell you
can i i'll tell you
what happened very simply in the state
of pennsylvania right
there are all sorts of issues with this
election
you're looking at changes that were made
in the middle of the game
right unconstitutional changes through
our election code and to voting
in the middle of the game right the
secretary of state in the state of
pennsylvania said we're going to remove
the signature verification
for ballast we're going to move any for
mail and balance we're going to remove
the postmark requirement for any mail-in
ballot we're going to remove any
semblance of a deadline for a mail-in
ballot this was just a few weeks before
the election
so my point is they used dirty games
they used covid
to create chaos at the top they changed
the rules at the last minute at the top
right and then add to that at the next
tier down
you had you know what i what i call
zuckerberg money
that was invested in heavily democratic
counties like allegheny county i think
got 2.2 million dollars
i don't know it wasn't from zuckerberg
directly but it was
it was from a cell corporation or
something like that you can look it up
on on google right now and find it
to pay election judges to boost their
salaries
right this is this is all just look it
up i i don't think that this is legal
by the way but i haven't seen lawsuits
on it yet but you bank on it there will
be lawsuits on this
where they boosted the salaries of
judges of elections they created remote
satellite uh voting facilities where
people could just show up at like an ice
rink and cast their ballot
and they and they funded dropbox yeah
and they funded drop boxes
so and then they had and then and then
beyond that
and and you had this this issue in
beaver county nursing homes that i've
looked at like
granny harvesting ballot harvesting in
nursing homes um
you had you have you have ballots and
issues of ballots of of
zero chains of custody in in pa 17 that
were cast
that we had stories and affidavits from
people who who have who heard people
voting twice right they
they mailed in a ballot and then they
voted provisional i mean there are all
sorts of issues with this and i'm not
all i'm saying right is that we should
look into it this is the first this is
the first time
that we've that we've used all mail-in
system or no excuse absentee system in
the state of pennsylvania
it's the first time it's ever happened
in the middle of a once in a hundred
year pandemic
is it not okay to think critically about
this and say let's
look into this a little bit to make sure
that everything went
as it was supposed to go because every
ballot that was cast illegally
cancels out a ballot of someone who
showed up on election day to vote
there's no political willpower
there's some there's there's listen it's
like i was it's like i was saying the
democrats will come into the
in congress and propose a bill to burn
down the house
and republicans will say only burn down
the kitchen i think we need
instead of arguing how about we don't
burn down the house they say well we'll
negotiate with you on what you're asking
for
what upsets me is that how is it the
responsibility of the citizen to prove
these things is it not the
responsibility of the government to
prove to the people
that their elections are free we are the
government yes and is it not the
responsibility of the media to be a
watchdog for the people and ask
real questions yes and this is why i'm
pretty pessimistic on where we go next
because the media in this country is
they're democrats that's true i mean the
the overall majority of all of these big
media companies
are pro-democrat they would not report
on hunter biden even though it's
probably one of the biggest stories of
the decade
or longer and so they're not watchdogs
they're advocates
and so you have advocates and we are
headed towards california-style
one-party rule
thanks for checking out this clip from
the tim cast irl podcast we do the show
live monday through friday at 8pm so
come back to check us out when we go
live
don't forget to subscribe hit the like
button hit the notification bell
and we are also available on all podcast
platforms for
free if you want to listen to us there
thanks for hanging out
and we will see you all next time
you